we know this because of Matt tauby's
reporting he's the author of griptopia
and he joins us tonight Matt thank you
so much for coming on so I'm not sure if
I summarize that fairly but I'll hand it
to you what do we know now
well I think we know a lot about uh how
a lot of these rusticated stories came
to be people just lied uh in this case
even when Twitter had more or less
conclusive proof that there were no
Russians involved in the release the
memo hashtag even when they inform media
and elected officials even when they
pleaded with members of the Senate not
to go public because it would make them
look quote foolish
they went ahead and did it anyway
despite being informed of the truth that
of course Twitter knew internally
because they were looking at the raw
data so this is I think a template of
how these stories came in uh came to be
the you know they the politicians in the
media just simply overrode what the
facts were and things being the way they
were the there was the real Mania at the
time this was the peak of the sort of
McCarthy hysteria about this subject
um there was just no turning back
so five years later we're now engaged in
a hot war with Russia which we are and
they're Americans fighting the war in
Ukraine against Russia so I wonder how
much of this was designed to divert
attention from things they didn't want
exposed and how much of it was an effort
to whip Americans into a frenzy about
Russia
I think at the time it seemed much more
about diverting attention from the news
memo because remember there were two
sets of fake stories that came out at
the time one was that the story was
being Amplified by Russian Bots and that
story by the way was repeated by
virtually every major news organization
in America and in some other countries
too like the CBC did that story
um but the other story was that the
Nunez memo was not just fake and not
just the completely devoid of any
important Revelations but grounds for
him to potentially be removed from his
position at the Intel committee
moveon.org had a petition about it of
course we found out two years later
through the inspector General's report
that virtually everything in the Nunez
memo had been proved correct so I think
that's what they were doing they were
just trying to deflect from an
uncomfortable Truth by calling him a
Russian proxy
really quick since I know that you're
keeping score has any news organization
that printed false allegations then
apologized now in light of the truth
coming out
not only have they not apologized but
not one of the news organizations that I
reached out to
um for comment about this particular
issue responded to me
um so I that which suggests to me that
they know exactly what happened they
know exactly how irresponsible they were
again this isn't a left or right issue
this is just simply a fact issue they
needed to be able to ask Twitter what
was going on and I don't think most of
these news organizations did that and
now they're reluctant to admit it yeah
and they're attacking you uh Matt Tybee
thank you for your reporting and for
telling us about tonight I appreciate it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else